yes you can only imagine the massive
headaches that would have been had by
his security detail as they planned how
to get the president into this country
which is a war zone and out again and
the National Security advisor has
reportedly said that the Russians were
alerted a few hours ahead of Mr Biden's
visit to help with the deconfliction of
the area you'll know of course from your
long time spent here in the capital that
the capital does at times come under
missile attack from the Russians while
the president was here visiting the
monastery behind me with the Ukrainian
president the air raid sirens were heard
but he does he has managed to come in
and go out again without incident
and what about the substance Deborah of
the
um you know what Joe Biden is offering
500 million dollars worth of of more
equipment adding to
what is it 30 billion dollars already
given to Ukraine
yes the U.S has by a long way been the
biggest and most important DACA of
Ukraine and clearly for the U.S
president the main message that he has
is sending to the Kremlin is that as we
prepare for this one-year anniversary of
Russia's full-scale Invasion with the
war still very much raging in the East
and no sign of the Russian side backing
down that the U.S and its allies are in
this for the Long Haul as well he said
to Vladimir zelenski in the public
statements that we've heard that the
United States is going to be sticking
alongside Ukraine and just to give you a
sense of people that I've been speaking
to here on the Square who've been coming
out and it's it's a popular place to
come to anyway as you know with these
relics of shattered Russian tanks in a
display of defiance that are here on the
Square and they hugely welcomed the U.S
president's visit I spoke to a
university official who was paying the
wall behind me which is this memorial
wall
um dedicated to the Fallen Soldiers of
this war which goes back to 2014 he was
paying tribute to some of the students
from Kiev University who've given their
lives in this conflict and he hugely
welcomed the president's visit he said
it really sort of demonstrated this
hugely important American supporter
superpower supporting Ukraine at its
time of Crisis it's time of need